and the Oscar goes
to Rick Baker and Gail Ryan for Dr Su
how the grin Stole Christmas we'd like
to thank the academy Universal imagine
Brian graser and Ron Howard for making
such a creative film the entire cast for
their patience and cooperation Jim Cary
for His Brilliant performance my crew
over
150 talented people contributed greatly
to the work that we accept this award
for I'm sorry I can't thank them all
individually but one I have to thank
tonight is Kazu hero suji Kazu not only
applied Jim car's Grinch makeup but
designed many of the makeups and
deserves to be here with us lastly I'd
like to thank the loves of my life my
beautiful wife Sylvia my fantastic
daughters Veronica and Rebecca my late
mother Doris and my father Ralph go
ahead I'd also like to thank my fabulous
crew um a special thanks to Terry balel
for his wonderful work tell my husband I
love him and Laurel I wish you were here
thank you